remember mythbusters throughout the
2000s and early 2010s mythbusters was
one of the most popular science based
shows in the entire world
every week we got to see their cast put
popular myths and urban legends to the
test is it likely that the alcatraz
prison escape was successful if you
drink that coke and instantly eat mentos
right after would your stomach explode
and most importantly could the jack and
rose have shared the door in titanic
myths like these kept many of us
addicted to the show for several years
but out of nowhere in late 2015 the
mythbusters announced that the longest
running show on the discovery channel
was coming to an end in 2016. for most
of us this was a complete surprise given
that the show was still as entertaining
as ever since then we've seen multiple
spin-offs emerge including mythbusters
the search white rabbit project
mythbusters jr and motor mythbusters
while some of these were great in their
own ride it was of course never as good
as the original
so what happened to mythbusters and why
was the show cancelled
while it may seem like mythbusters ended
abruptly there was actually a slow
fundamental issues that played the team
for years one of these issues was the
chemistry between the team members
themselves specifically adam and jaime
now this might come as a surprise to
many of you but adam and jaime aren't
actually friends and this isn't
speculation or some sort of fan theory
both of them have actually been
extremely transparent about how they
don't actually get along in real life
adam said quote we don't get along very
well together on a personal level in the
25 years that we've known each other
we've never had dinner alone together
similarly when asked if it would be an
exaggeration to say that jamie didn't
really like adam jamie replied
noah we certainly had respect for each
other but we really weren't friends
considering this it's extremely
impressive that this duo was able to
sustain such a productive professional
relationship for so long but if it was
up to them they wouldn't voluntarily
work with each other in other words the
opportunity to work together didn't keep
them on the show by any means they each
had their own independent reasons to do
the show and when those reasons
dissolved it they didn't hesitate to
split ways if you're wondering about the
relationship between tory kerry and
grant these guys were basically the
exact opposite of adam and jaime they
got along extremely well in fact here's
what grant had to say about it the three
of us you tori and i we are beyond
friends we are siblings we shared a
long-a-wild adventure learning from each
other the whole way
our cameraman nicknamed us technical
practical and logical because we were so
different but we could solve any problem
together clearly this trio liked working
with each other but that wasn't enough
to deter them from leaving the show when
the time came either you see interest in
mythbusters was slowly declining over
the years now i know what makes a lot of
you guys upset when i say things like
this because yes even after the decline
mythbusters was still super popular
however when you're constantly trying to
produce bigger seasons with bigger myths
and bigger budgets it's not really
sustainable when viewership and ratings
are declining and according to the data
the decline was pretty clear take a look
at google trends for example the search
data says that interest and myth busters
peaked between 2006 and 2008. there were
two singular peaks in 2009 and 2011 but
for the most part the underlying decline
continued and by the time the show ended
it was only pulling in 20 to 30 percent
of the interest that it was pulling in
during its peak
and if you don't believe google just
listen to adam himself describe the
issue
so mythbusters was on for 14 years
uh every everything in the world has its
own bell curve so we signed that
contract when our ratings were at their
absolute peak and then slowly over the
next five years they started their their
slide they still was respectable ratings
by the end but that slide happened so
while mythbusters were still quite
popular and adored by super fans the
average viewer was starting to tune out
and this makes sense given that the
mythbusters had already tested the most
popular myths there's only so many jack
and rose scenes and water white scenes
that everyone knows
sooner or later you're gonna have to
tackle less popular myths that aren't as
appealing to the general audience and
eventually this led to declining ratings
which took a toll on the show
one of the first shortfalls that was
extremely evident to viewers was what
happened to tory grant and kerry in 2014
it was announced that the b cast would
be eliminated and that the show would
simply focus on adam and jaime according
to the producers what grant carrie and
tori were asking for was unreasonable we
never really got a solid explanation as
to what exactly they asked for or why
negotiations didn't end up fruitful at
first there was some speculation that
this trio might have grown some
resentment for each other just like adam
and jaime but they would soon turn
around and star in the white rabbit
project together so this likely wasn't
the case the more likely scenario is
that the trio wanted to maintain their
compensation or increase it and given
the viewership was declining it this
simply wasn't feasible something else to
note is that it seemed like the trio did
not agree with the direction that the
producers for taking mythbusters
instead of myths being at the center of
each episode it felt like the producers
wanted more explosions and theatrics
they probably thought that this would
help retain viewers but it kind of just
caused the show to lose its original
appeal once carrie grant and tori were
removed from the show ratings just
declined even faster while some viewers
were indifferent to the change most
viewers were upset that they were cut
from the show they felt that the trio
gave a healthy break from the antics of
adam and jaime also carrie was the only
woman that was left on the show
and given that stem fields are generally
skewed towards men many young girls
looked up to carry but unfortunately
this didn't last moving on to the last
two seasons of mythbusters given that
the cast was cut in half the number of
myths tested per show was also cut in
half each episode only covers two mids
instead of three or four like before
on the bright side this allowed the
producers to spend more time showing the
engineering behind each project adam and
jaime also had more time to explain the
science behind each experiment while
these facets were welcomed by superfans
to the average viewer this likely just
felt slower paced and not as exciting
and soon enough adam and jaime's
five-year contract was coming to an end
as well meaning that it was time to
renegotiate adam was actually super
transparent about this stating that he
simply wasn't willing to do the show for
less compensation
do you keep the show going well
discovery's not going to want to pay us
more to keep on doing the show and
frankly after 14 years and i'm 50 now
i'm tired i'm definitely not going gonna
do the show for less and given that
discovery wasn't willing to allocate a
bigger budget the only option was to
shut it down the silver lining is the
discovery that jamie and adam and the
show on their terms they were allowed to
call it a final season and they were
able to test some of the biggest myths
yet but the best part was that they were
able to invite kyrie torre and grant to
do a wrap up episode this conclusion was
extremely well received by the fans
given that it was the highest rated
mythbusters episode of all time so while
it was a shame that mythbusters came to
an end earlier than people wanted it's
nice that the show at least got the
ending that it deserved
in terms of what the mythbusters are up
to today they've all gone down their own
paths starting with adam while he left
mythbusters he never really gave up the
show business he went on to host two
more shows called the mythbusters junior
and savage builds
given the name mythbusters jr i don't
think you'd be surprised here that he
had a similar premise to the original
show instead of how adults test these
mitts however he had teenagers and adam
was basically their mentor leading them
through the design assembly and testing
processes as for savage builds this show
was focused on new inventions and
restoration projects adam collaborated
with industry experts and friends to
make things like the iron man suit and
the wheel of death savage builds
actually performed quite well however
both of these shows were canceled after
just one season adam wasn't just
involved in tv shows either he also had
a cameo in 2048 didn't know where to run
it and he published a book called every
tool as a hammer life is what you make
it likely his most significant project
over the past several years however is
his youtube channel adam became the face
of the youtube channel tested and they
even renamed the channel to adam
savage's tested the channel has nearly 6
million subscribers and they post a new
video almost every day about science and
the building anyway moving on to jaime
his life after mythbusters hasn't been
nearly as eventful he has more or less
left the show business and has mainly
focused on personal projects for example
he built a tank that's specifically
designed for firefighting he also
received an honorary doctorate in
technology from la penrantan university
of technology in 2017. this was actually
his third honorary doctorate he had
previously received one from villanova
university and the university of tuente
more recently he was appointed as a
professor at luck university in november
of 2021 this was a five-year contract so
this is probably where i'll spend the
majority of his time in the coming years
moving on to tori he's basically just
jumped from one show to another shortly
after mythbusters ended he started
hosting a show called the thrill factor
with kerry the show focuses on the
science and engineering behind roller
coasters and amusement park rides and
explains why certain attractions are so
thrilling after throw factor torrey went
on to host white rabbit project with of
course carrion grant he took a few years
off from the show business after white
rabbit project but he eventually
returned in 2019 with the great
escapists since then he's also appeared
on the explosion show and the jackass
forever so things haven't changed all
that much for tori the same can be said
about kerry as well she of course also
hosted welfare and white rabbit project
but she's done a few things on her own
as well for example she hosted crash
test world this show focuses on the tech
capitals of the world and how these
various cities are helping build our
future aside from starring in these
shows carrie also helped found an
educational streaming service called
explore media the streaming service is
still super new so we'll have to see how
it plays out and finally last but
definitely not least we have grant after
mythbusters and white rabbit project
rand went on to host the second season
of home of the future as the name
suggests this show focuses on futuristic
homes filled with the newest tech grant
also had a cameo in the tv movie
sharknado 3. grant hasn't just been
working on the front end of movies and
tv shows either he also spent a lot of
time on the back end as well for example
in 2017 he consulted with the disney for
six months to help them build better
animatronics while things were going
pretty good for granted career-wise he
would unfortunately be hit with an
intracranial aneurysm in july of 2020
which took his life he was only 49 years
old at the time which leaves him with
the most tragic ending
while it's already been several years
since mythbusters ended i'd be blank to
bet that the effect of mythbusters will
live on for decades mythbusters inspired
millions of kids and teenagers to pursue
careers in science and engineering and
who knows what these young minds will
come up with in the coming decades in
terms of the show itself ending it it
really just came down to declining
viewership and a limited budget but
honestly i don't think it's necessarily
a bad thing more times than not we see
shows go on for way too long
mythbusters was able to end off at a
time where viewers still wanted more
which is why all of us still remember it
in such a positive light even after all
these years
and i'm not sure if any other ending
could have created such a lasting effect
but that's just what i think did you
watch mythbusters growing up comment
that down below also drop a like if
you're glad that mythbusters ended up
strong and of course consider joining
our discord community suggested ideas
and consider subscribing to more
questions possibly answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you